Hace 25 años, los científicos del CERN crearon la World Wide Web.
Desde entonces, Internet ha transformado la forma de comunicarnos,
la forma de hacer negocios e incluso de vivir.
En muchos sentidos,
las ideas que dieron origen a Google, Facebook, Twitter, y tantos otros,
ahora han transformado nuestras vidas,
y esto nos ha traído muchos beneficios reales como una sociedad más conectada.
Sin embargo, también tiene algunos aspectos negativos.
Hoy, la persona promedio tiene una enorme cantidad
de información personal en línea,
y sumamos a esta información en línea cada vez que publicamos en Facebook,
cada vez que buscamos en Google,
y cada vez que enviamos un email.
Muchos pensamos que probablemente,
no hay nada en un email, ¿verdad?
Pero si vemos un año de correos,
o incluso una vida de correos,
en conjunto dice mucho.
Dice dónde hemos estado, a quiénes conocimos,
y en muchos aspectos, incluso qué estamos pensando.
Y lo más aterrador de todo es que nuestros datos ahora duran para siempre,
los datos pueden y nos van a sobrevivir.
En gran medida hemos perdido el control de los datos
y también nuestra privacidad.